reason while we're doing again because
you've got the waiting no no no I
founded no energy look you are you were
there you were when talking to you yeah
you look like a crossing today stopping
women hitting next might look like a
very serious issue but men make up
anywhere from 29 to 40 percent of all
domestic abuse victims reported us right
female victims of domestic violence we
know that every 15 seconds a woman is
battered but how often is a man battered
by a woman in the United States well the
number is same every 15 seconds at least
according to Richard gelas gelas is
considered one of the country's leading
experts on domestic violence he has made
a career of talking to victims and
perpetrators and what he's discovered is
that the women are is likely to initiate
the vials as the men and what I want to
do today I look at the culture that
allows for that to happen for men to be
underrepresented when it comes to this
issue so as I have interview some people
and asked them if they were cool with
getting shorter and last more
consequences hey let's go Wow see high
energies what's on the bat maybe not
scream in my ear it's not bad can you
not try to do too much no no no comment
I don't know no no like I'm too
easygoing no so then we decided to ask
exact same question to it oh boy hit
them yeah you're done Lou I love talking
more like a love slap in the face you
know what
slap slap - your face Laura yeah my door
hope you don't look just like frustrate
me piss me off I get nervous buff
definitely happen women that I've been
with that yeah exactly the idea I all be
frustrated might get mad so give a tap
as a dancer not even talk about just
kind of stupid we
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah this happens one
time I was it was like right after we
were having sex like I just finished and
we were just lying there for a second
and I would try to actually like call
them at it but I guess it was a weird
coffeemakers I'll say how like I loved
how she like grabbed on the sheets and
like squeeze their fingers and I kind of
like imitated what you did and she just
slapped me full-on across the face like
both laugh and I was like what the [ __ ]
she's I don't imitate what I do when I
have sex and they're like you can't be
aggressive to one of the females
no I'm ago no better not well I mean I
don't know I kind of have a double
standard for that also I feel like I
just dropped any guy who would even
pretend to slap me in the face okay but
I'm totally cool it's locking them in
the bed
I think they would be surprised how many
women engage in physical violence
the Sacramento program is one of just a
handful of anger management programs in
the u.s. targeted toward women who abuse
their male partners you think that um
ket nothing happen to you I mean you
just can go through life and do it and
do it and hit and slap and punch and I
thought it's totally cool yeah oh yeah
and yourself hypocrisy decides the
reason why women's believe they should
not get hit back by men it's even more
ridiculous you know it's don't answer
hit a girl and let your light isn't
[Applause]
great different now strange this is the
reason he write yeah because because the
man is stronger than the woman therefore
you cannot hit a woman but strength
difference doesn't work if it did I give
- leaving some submits and every time
somebody pissed me off in the [ __ ] to
beat the [ __ ] up well let me show you
back let me weave the hobbits a little
distraint difference that's not is not
about strength is just very simple it's
the same reason when the Titanic is
sinking all you ladies get to leave with
the kids once man has to stay on the
boat and die right
apparently we decided years and years
ago that women's lives were made to be
protected and we're more valuable than
men somehow right so that idea of gender
roles is still very pervasive we expect
men to live by the rules the past when
it comes to women that's not necessarily
the case if you try to impose gender
worlds on girls they start to freak out
but I just wish I could go to one of my
ex-girlfriends assistant Stephanie I
know you were straight A's
why you Stephanie go you know that my
girlfriend give me two seconds you're
about the experience and ligament lot of
clothes you have to use that's me when I
went out there so I want to go you
forget about you donating that puzzle to
add you look like a statue
yes so what so use something else why
come when you really go out with like a
Paula
wait you think you're the only one read
a [ __ ] Stephanie like a Steve I did
it Stephanie - yeah no you did yeah this
tell me something Oh step off my last
name to see what you don't even don't
dare pull up some pictures - who wants
to later hey I was thought if any man
ever says anything to me it's
inappropriate I get to slap him and
Hollywood teaches that lesson to the
latitude of women get is is more
substantial they have a great free fire
zone
sometimes I go to YouTube when I watch
girls that get hit back
[Music]
don't do it baby listen listen she looks
like she got hit with a subwoofer no no
she wasn't ready she wasn't ready by
physical and the psychological
repercussions of being abused by the
Department of the man is just an
elevator as if it was for a woman the
big difference is we have extreme large
amounts of funding that go to women for
being by their partners even though men
make up to 40% of all domestic abuse
victims they get less than 4% of funding
so there's definitely discrepancy in the
way our society views it how serious the
problem is and how we allocate funds to
the issue some say even our nation's
lawmakers have looked the other way back
in 1994 Congress passed the Violence
Against Women Act or valla it's 1.6
billion tax dollars people we talked
with all agree that vow has done good
things for women but most say it has
done little or nothing for men 1 Justice
Department official told us flat-out
quote the program is designed to assist
women and take a look at this Justice
Department document obtained by Fox 5 it
acknowledges that for the purposes of
VAWA the department refers to quote
victims as women and perpetrators as men
so if there are men who are victims of
domestic violence it seems that there
would be shelters to house those men we
searched the whole country and found
just one domestic violence shelter that
accepts men founded here in the middle
of the California desert and what else I
see that even ice and any causally that
women should not to piss but does not
mean we have to ignore the other side
and forget these people because then
their experience even more marginalized
you don't say equal rights so this way
Catherine Q Becker is accused of cutting
off her husband's penis with a knife
taking his penis and throwing it into
the garbage disposal Issei Becker
attacked him because he filed for
divorce she's being helped she goes out
of Egypt
I don't know why he filed for divorce I
don't know what was going on between
them however I do think it's quite
fabulous
I mean whizzing around America I don't
want to live on this planet anymore oh
my god you're not even dad served by the
hook I'm not because I say function on a
regular basis what really pisses me out
remember Don Imus you know dynamics was
yeah he on the radio and he said so I
watched the basketball game last night
between a little bit of rust errs and
Tennessee the women's final awesome
rough girls from Rutgers man they got
tattoos and some hardcore hoes I'm
finessin nappy-headed oliveira
nappy-headed own a free road and lost
the job the next day these legs can get
on live television and talk about the
fact that man LOX is penis and may not
survive and they can laugh about it when
I thought about some general relational
thing stops me down how you doing oh
yeah yeah when he couldn't clitoris yeah
when they cut a clitoris with that
involve your leg okay [ __ ] no beans
boom it's a dry harvest okay I gave it
all this is character named Dennis and
there's a unit in the unit is
essentially a person whose penis has
been cut off from any updates you okay
now here's the thing everybody died in
the assault but this very character
refuses to die and I'm like [ __ ] you
ain't got no dick why he's still
fighting to live you should be one of
the first characters to die and people
like well I would still got his balls
I'm like that's even worse yeah that's
like highly the good with no ammunition
what the [ __ ] I having ammunition would
know that when men cannot hit women
wearing it then you don't know other
people's trauma you don't know what
they've been through in their life for
you to just insert yourself into
cleaning other people's bubble is a big
risk that you're taking it to think that
there's no repercussions when you take
those risks is ridiculous society should
not protect you for you being an [ __ ]
yeah I'm saying I agree man should not
hit women I feel like women should hit
men people shouldn't hit people that
mean all it comes down never that's what
he qualms all about the fact that we
treat each other with respect and
understand each other's boundaries I
would never go up to priests to start
hitting again when I get fresh
better not girl I'm David I've come up
to me and just have you like this when
you get frustrated Alan where do you get
off getting into my bubble like that
when you are upset about something why
can't you just communicate why are you
so lazy that you think okay to take
control the situation by hitting me
every time a girl's done that objective
I said you hit me again I'll slap you so
hard across the face you're gonna wish
you did it and good with stare they're
going to look at me like that
did you just say that I never look at
this how serious I am
and it's only when you realize that I'm
serious that they stop and it's because
us man we understand those boundaries we
never think of crossing that well women
because you guys have this card blocks
you guys are a little bit like dictators
we give you an inch you go oh my and
that look my thing is I just wish people
would stop telling people right where we
learned to communicate with our words
become better communicators and from
that point we could better coexist I
think this whole thing about hitting
people would feel frustrated and mostly
angry it's late and I just want us here
to do better so that's pretty much a
dream great for what you think rookies
all right so that's it for today's video
if you guys like that be sure to LIKE
subscribe Facebook YouTube we don't put
everything on Facebook because YouTube's
our main bits follow us on Instagram all
that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want
don't need a little bit of money you
know it was a little zone zone zone then
we do a little time no no we don't do I
definitely went the wrong direction job
well that's yes so you know thanks
holler a dollar makes me holler